what's going on you go nice thank you
how's life so it's just a walk for you
are you living at home here in Vancouver
I wish now do you have a long-standing
relationship with David Foster is that
what happens when you hit a billion
streams on YouTube people just like you
have to come
so why aside from obviously the personal
relationship why was it important to you
to be here tonight more attention we can
bring you to trying to raise money for
these families and for these children
who are going through the hardest time
in their life all of our attention
should be paid to words yeah and you
also give back in other ways I heard you
just married your friends not too long
ago so how do you do that you got a
certificate to be an ordained so what
about new music won't we expect it
what's going on
yes I think yeah I mean I I'm an
overeater sounds wow really my favorites
and making sure feels cohesive been like
the right next is it amazing to be able
to take your time with it and figure out
exactly what you want to do with this
project I enjoy that process it doesn't
not drive you a little insane but it's a
mean it's my process and I can't judge
it too much because it seems to be the
only way I go at it you perform it
tonight I am I am okay yeah look after
your little bit later than thank you
good to see you